the Supreme Court just ruled that it is
now legal for sex offenders to use
social media legal force yeah when asked
to explain the decision the justices
said sex offenders on the Internet
what's the worst that could happen
what's the worst that could happen maybe
not that funny now it's funny huh okay I
guess give it a little time and now
they're happy president Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner is right now in
the middle east to broker a historic
peace between Israel and the
Palestinians yeah Kushner thinks real
progress will start once both sides stop
laughing
why is he there no who is he I have I
have no I was an intern on our show a
week ago I know you want some coffee mr.
O'Brian I gotta go my father-in-law
wants me to broker Middle East peace
speaking of Israel interesting story I
think it's interesting he'll come along
in Israel a court ruled that a religious
man cannot force a woman to move seats
on an airplane just because he's afraid
of having accidental physical contact
with her yes was the landmark case of
Israel versus Mike Pence
[Music]
hey big story the reality show bachelor
in paradise this is okay that tells me
so much okay nobody showed bachelor in
paradise has been cleared of the assault
charges and it's going to resume filming
great yeah yeah the news was celebrated
today by ABC the contestants and the
chlamydia virus this whole section here
watches bachelor in paradise
we're right bats from paradise right
here this is a whole section of I don't
understand I know I guess you get to see
people hook up right I guess you were on
that show you were the bachelor 1 year
you were no oh you were doing it I
remember that season it was bachelor in
paradise Cleveland yeah my wife was
pissed yeah they all get mad but then
you see that check come in all right
this is crazy Girl Scouts did you know
this Girl Scouts can now earn a badge
for cybersecurity Girl Scouts can get a
bag for 70 yeah yeah yeah that explains
why there's a mysterious seven thousand
dollar charge on your credit card for
thin mints
no that's they're not gonna come door to
door any more than we like and thank you
very much weird story out of California
in some California jails inmates are now
allowed to upgrade to nicer cells which
have cable TV
private phones and personal libraries
yeah yeah that explains the hot new
trend getting arrested
that was pretty good you better talk
about The Bachelor again I'll see you
ladies later huh huh no I won't see
those ladies later whenever I say I'll
see you ladies later it means I've never
seen those ladies again Burger King
that's right Burger King has just I'm
not done yet a guy can't just say Burger
King and then walk off the stage what
have I just said kind of Mike and I went
Burger King and dropped it and walked
off it would be like that was stupid
Burger King has just come out with a
Lucky Charms cereal milkshake
yeah yeah it's all part of their new
slogan when you're here you're probably
high
you